okay okay Ernest Borgnine let's do the
door opening one more time Jan Sylvania
Turkey we'll do that
when will people learn no more
Transylvania turkeys I'm sorry wait what
the hell kind of Turkey how come you
weren't infected I'm German when I don't
blood does resistance at all diseases of
the foul but it will get me soon enough
well what do we do now but that's not a
guarantee yeah I know we call it taken
in delivered but I think we deliver
little because
of course not because you never liked
anyone I now one of the key things about
making a film especially one with you
know a big person you know under throw
people around and stuff you know even
though I am very muscular is that you
had to be sure that everybody is kept
safe safety is the most important on
these things I mean you just can't have
people running around thinking like they
know what they're gonna do with you know
whether be a weapon or you know where's
Quinn where's Quinn I'm just gonna go
ahead and film this yeah like maybe one
two feathers that you like in the hair
as well looks like you ate Mickey Mouse
we got Thanksgiving coming up I was
thinking something that was timeless
classic and a little nostalgic let's say
wreck-it Ralph hey let's say
sugar rush looks like a Candyland farted
out Mario Kart mastermind behind the
whole video game takeover was it some
Mario